we're draw them into the shallow water
on a draw min and drown them well and I
do do you Miss Manners ladies the
shallows is directed by hua Mei Colette
Sarah
I tried SARS Blake Lively and is the
story of a young girl who's going
surfing and she gets stranded in the
shallows on a rock when she's injured by
a great white shark
she's 200 yards away from shore but the
only way that she can get there is if
she swims there but this shark means
business and now we have a contained
small thriller I was extremely excited
for the shallows for a number of reasons
for one it's a shark movie look behind
me I like shark films I really do but
also it was like Hollywood stopped
taking shark movie seriously now all we
get is mega shark versus mega octopus
and sharknado 7 we never get good shark
movies anymore so I was pumped for this
movie also this director is someone I
find very underrated he's made three
really fun Liam Neeson movies unknown
non-stop and run all night his first
movie House of Wax with Paris Hilton was
kind of bad but he was definitely the
best part of it and he made the very
underrated film orphan so I've kind of
been behind this guy for a long time so
for a lot of reasons bless Blake Lively
Dean I was excited for the shallows now
that I've actually seen the shallows
what can I say the shallows is the best
shark film since jaws unfortunately
that's really not saying much
for over 40 years jaws has been the king
of shark movies and it continues to be
the shallows I thought was a perfectly
fun thriller it unfortunately does not
reach the dramatic heights that I wanted
it to it doesn't reach those Heights
that I think it's even aiming for it's a
very serious film at times you have this
backstory with our main character played
by Blake Lively with something that
happened to our family in the past a
tragedy of sorts and it goes back to
that from time to time sort of a 127
hours style where she's remembering
things thinking she might die I'm not
going to say that the movie is taking
itself too seriously what I'm going to
say is that it doesn't reach those
Heights it's a
for because if it did and it felt more
authentic then the more dramatic side of
this movie would have felt more real and
it would have felt more earned the movie
is fun though there are some sequences
that genuinely had me white-knuckling
the armrest of my seat and Blake Lively
is very good in this movie this is
definitely one of her better
performances she has to spend the
majority of the film in a very
heightened state of trauma and she
pulled it off the shark is also very
well realized it's a very good CG shark
my big issue with the shallows is
unfortunately the tone this movie has a
very conflicting tone it starts out with
a lot of contemporary pop music
electronic dance style music and it
feels kind of like a music video or
commercial for GoPros and then it gets
very serious and more thrilling with the
shark and everything and you get into
more intense score and more music like
that but unfortunately the film was
unable to sustain a feeling of suspense
the movie Jaws opens with instantaneous
suspense there's like 15 seconds of
black screen and underwater noises
you're instantly sucked in feeling like
a little uneasy this movie doesn't have
that it feels very modern and
contemporary with some of the music
choices and unfortunately some of the
way that it's directed there's an
overuse of slow-mo in this movie that
really started to bug me and although it
looks really good the movie itself has a
very beautiful color palette the water
and the scenery and obviously Blake
Lively it all looks really good the
movie itself wasn't able to sustain much
suspense and it wasn't all that scary
for me one of my major complaints with
this movie is storytelling based it sets
up a plot point of some kind something
the main character is very curious about
she keeps asking people this question
and we go back to this question many
times throughout the movie and it's
supposed to be this element that makes
you curious and draws you more into the
story and it gives you something to
wonder and expect and then it's just
dropped and never referred to again and
you walk out not knowing and I was kind
of like what was that all about
still for me this is a very good what I
call rainy day thriller in fact this
director makes a lot of those there are
thrill rides that are fun kind of
disposable you forget about them quickly
but they hole
your interest fairly well while you're
watching it and if it's raining outside
you have nothing better to do pop in the
shallows or run all night or unknown or
non-stop he makes a lot of movies like
that that are sort of disposable
thrillers but they're well-made
competently directed for the most part
and exciting to watch sometimes there
were some weak story elements and some
strange music choices and this
suspenseful tone wasn't very well
utilized but still I overall enjoyed
watching the shadows and I'm going to
give it a B so guys speaking of shark
movies you guys know that last week my
friend and I'm at Brando we reviewed
jaws 3d for the very first time we got
to watch it actually in 3d now the
blu-ray is out if you guys didn't get a
chance to see that video there's going
to be annotation at the very end here
for it and this sunday i am going to
have my review of jaws - finally I will
complete my jaws quadrilogy of reviews
Matt and I rewatched it and we had a lot
of fun talking about it and something
very special happens at the end of that
video a very cool surprise that I am
very excited about and hope you guys get
a chance to watch it thank you so much
as always for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes